[Music]
throughout
six centuries the ghent altarpiece has
been burned
forged and raided in three different
wars
it is in fact the world's most stolen
artwork and while it's told some of its
secrets
it's kept others hidden in 1934 the
police of
ghent belgium heard that one of the
altarpiece's panels
split between its front and back was
suddenly
gone the commissioner investigated the
scene
but determined that a theft at a cheese
shop was more pressing
twelve ransom notes appeared over the
following months
and one half of the panel was even
returned as a show of good faith
meanwhile art restorer jeff van der
veeken
made a replica of the other half for
display until it was found
but it never was some suspected that he
was involved in the theft and once
ransomed demands failed
had simply painted over the original and
presented it as his copy
but a definitive answer wouldn't come
for decades
just six years later hitler was planning
a grand museum
but was missing his most desired
possession
the ghent altarpiece as nazi forces
advanced
belgian leaders sent the painting to
france
but the nazis commandeered and moved it
to a salt mine
converted into a stolen art warehouse
that contained over 6 000
masterpieces near the war's end in 1945
a nazi official decided he'd rather blow
up the mine
before letting it fall into allied hands
in fact the allies had soldiers called
monuments men
who were tasked with protecting cultural
treasures
two of them were stationed 570
kilometers away
when one got a toothache they visited a
local dentist
who mentioned that his son-in-law also
loved art and took them to meet him
they discovered that he was actually one
of the nazis former art advisors
now in hiding and miraculously
he told them everything the monuments
men devised a plan
to rescue the art and the local
resistance delayed the mind's
destruction until they arrived
inside they found the altarpiece among
other world
treasures the ghent altarpiece also
called the
adoration of the mystic lamb after its
central subject
consists of twelve panels depicting the
biblical story
it's one of the most influential
artworks ever made
when jan van ike completed it in ghent
in 1432
it was immediately deemed the best
painting in europe
for millennia artists used tempera paint
consisting of ground pigment in egg yolk
which created vivid but
opaque colors the altarpiece was the
first
to showcase the unique abilities of oil
paint
they allowed van ike to capture light
and movement in a way that had never
been seen before
he did this using brushes sometimes as
tiny as a single badger hair
and by depicting details like ghent
landmarks botanically identifiable
flowers
and lifelike faces the altarpiece
pioneered an artistic mode
that would come to be known as realism
yet conservation work completed in 2019
found that for centuries people had been
viewing
a dramatically altered version due to
dozens of restorations
as much as 70 of certain sections had
been painted over
as conservators removed these layers of
paint
varnish and grime they discovered
vibrant colors
and whole buildings that had long been
invisible
other details were more unsettling
the mystic lamb's four ears had long
perplexed viewers but the conservation
team revealed
that the second pair was actually a
pentimento
the ghost of underlying layers of paint
that emerged
as newer ones fade restorers had painted
over the original lamb
with what they deemed a more palatable
version
they removed this over painting and
discovered the original
to be shockingly humanoid the
conservators
also finally determined whether van der
veeken had simply returned the missing
panel from 1934
he hadn't it was confirmed to be a copy
meaning the original is still missing
but there was one final clue
againt stockbroker while on his deathbed
a year after the theft
revealed an unsent ransom note
it reads it rests in a place where
neither i
nor anybody else can take it away
without arousing the attention of the
public
against detective remains assigned to
the case but
while there are new tips every year it
has yet
to be found world war ii was
rife with arts intrigue and adding fuel
to the fire
was the most notorious art forger of the
20th century
check out our video on han van meegeren
a con man so talented
he might even fool you